safety systems of space critical path of
the company said wednesday that they
need to be protected downtime vacation
continues operation on the intercompany
google cloud can help you improve your
sap systems up time and the worst of
options for design in high availability
architectures hi my name  is benjamin
schule the video from google
[music]
as before looking up the scp
specifications highlights of the box
concerts will google cloud can offer to
improve the uptime of any virtual
machine running and google computer
engine google cloud is an ideal world for
design where it ends  infrastructure of
data centers around the world that
contain jones design to be independent
familia the bloody deed noted indicated
that are available to the polls indicate
cherry jones josef individual power
cooling network and control planes the
slate fr the otherwise rather for single
fields event work for example bulldozer
cutting crew network caterings have
here construction bank edward  effect
without single source you can read in
google cloud service at least the laser
which enables our customers to design
high availability architecture across
multiple sons in rietschen at the
meeting us auto sector parts of the
world and storage software jones the
first state local edge available at
architect  google cloud offers is
chip leader instance sp cross different
than the same origin above red
back in action decision of the big white
label we want to say i chen mingxian
operating system expects option
us car manufacturer users rating the blogger
for the features of the big things mourning
virtualized infrastructure when  we need
to performance power infrastructure
google computation automatically
microsystems away from the people in the
event while trying to keep your
application running with me down drive
the feature live migration
the user interaction and the featured
bidder rhj the mic raid instance is
developed the origin instance including
the  instance d  ie rolling stones meter
data and storage each cell phone feature
competition will google compute engine is
our automatically start of virtual
machine for instance sz terminator
interesting event fia instance crashes
the cause of an expected to you can set
up computers cincotta medical restart
sheet instance the setting is  found on by
default and all virtual machine instance
sentry recommend that you keep this
feature activated in combination with a
star talk script you cannot major
sap-systems tat after work out any money
user activity and therefore the assets
impact on user significantly in some
cases you  might already know the ability
requirements at running of systems an
google cloud infrastructure us auto never
completed components of time and money
when it comes to run sap hana database
availability setup deals mechanism it
comes to mind first picture in hanna system
application of the box johanna instance
in tunis in English sun protect your
system added  failure of one's own
wheelchair meeting the requirements
tracing publication operation from
instances in the witcher information
templates for infrastructure
provisioning service manager of the
script pin up to 11
because conficker systems applications and
source linux cluster image autonews
interaction foley auto made in lets him out
for the manager  scale-out hanna
systems scenario was multiple mozah
connected to form one combined database
jugend edition standby not that can take
over encase one of the world as you can
see in the program of data and
locations on it's not a patch to the
single virtual machine instance
example here worker not to is no longer
available and immediately takes over the
data and location satie patch from work
out to end mounted the gem that is
executed at the storage plug in the works
with the city storage connect ideal the
standby not can on function as new
yorker mode and monster field worker
noticed more holes network the pace
is google cloud josef the option
students nun hanna databases check out
our database planning and deployment
guide like heinz link dies databases
hefter and build and functionality
sibylle thierer connector for example
standby services cps as always on option
mobility cluster on ibms db2 database
for your application servers  the first
components of the tube chair one to protect
the dance downtime central services in
the database this present impossible
single point of failure designer should
be protected you can trust the defense
services and multiple instances software
server running the message service
center server running the enco service
if  your message service instant sale the
instance running the grandson service
catalog information and continue to
users to be said that the us is one of
the benefits of running system an google
cloud infrastructure is diabetic
provision news service in the madoff
second and i mate die in translation
forces with this flex  ibility you can get
me you application servers ready for use
as they needed and with running multiple
instance the can immediately local
search server performance is
okay let's have a general statement it
can be said that move in sap system
front races hardware to google cloud
infrastructure can  improve the
availability who built and concepts on
the virtualisation late night live
migration and how to restored or for
improved the uptime where there is automatic
configuration downtimes chaos with
hardware features can be used to
eliminate woodwing annika city before the
data base layer barrios concept 6 is
the  penning at the best tip kick
ladies concepts based on a regular copy
of the database growth rate system os
set of database instance is running in
some sort of sink the application
motors set up to data base instance
should be placed in the friends else
where that  he him google squeak in front of
the heias level on ice surfaces wall
street english diamonds fo  r low latency
and finally an application layer of the sap
netweaver architecture and ride and
users with multiple application servers
to ensure the shadow of one instance
does not -blog all users for mac system
changes blues connection no login bayer
server should immediately steal the flexible
infrastructure google  ein auto
made it clear scripts venue application
server can be added on demand and
placing multiple application servers in
loosen group knows reputation of uptime on
the application layer hop des brief
video as new idea of the very high avail
bility architecture of google cloud
band bot inforadio  scp
workloads you can find the water for
discher information about scp and google
steals the youtube channel documentation
jackos linkstation quad
[Music]